[Music]  in the indian city of amritsar there is  a shining temple that is one of the most  visited places in the world  the harmandir sahib or the golden temple  is the chief house of worship for the  sikh religion  the name literally translates to house  of god  and millions of sikhs travel to the  temple every month on pilgrimage  surrounded by a pool of holy water the  temple was founded in 1574 to be a place  of worship for men and women of all  walks of life to worship equally  the temple was constructed out of marble  and copper and is covered with a layer  of gold foil giving the temple its  signature shine  perhaps the most impressive part of the  temple is the langer the seek community  kitchen  every day they provide more than 100 000  free meals in one of the largest  kitchens in the world  no matter of visitors reason for going  to the golden temple they will surely be  impressed by the architecture history  and community  [Music]  you